Hello world,
it's a Raj.
And today I want to talk about
blockchain for supply chain management.
In this video I'll talk about
the market for supply chain,
how blockchain can affect it.
Uh,
I'll demo this APP that I've compiled
and I've run locally called asset tracker
that uses solidity, uh, to create
an asset on the blockchain.
This is on the test rink be
etherium network and I'll
talk about how that works.
I'll go over the only legit blockchain
supply company that I could find called
Sync Fab,
how they work,
what they're doing with their
version of an ERC 20 token.
And then I'll cut it out.
I'll code out in solidity and asset
tracker that runs on the theory and
blockchain. Okay, so that's what
we're going to do in this video.
We're going to create a decentralized
supply chain app for asset tracking. Okay.
So the supply chain industry is huge
and it's only going to grow over time.
So the Americas, Asia, Africa, right?
These are all markets that are big and
the developing countries in particular,
um,
particularly on the coast of Africa are
going to grow exponentially over time.
And parts of Asia as well.
So the supply chain industry
is not going anywhere.
It's been around for a
while and it will be,
it's here right now and it
will be here in the future. Uh,
and so this is a very big industry.
And for those of you who don't
know what the supply chain is,
whenever you are the, the path that
any product you have in your home,
your shirt, your desk, your
computer, you know, whatever,
it follows a path of intermediaries to
get from the factory where it was created
to you. And that chain, uh, includes
distributors. It includes, um,
uh,
procurement officers,
people who are quality
inspection officers. It goes
through different channels,
right? It's not just like direct
from manufacturer to the end user.
The consumer rights, there's like four
or five, six, sometimes, you know,
a dozen intermediaries in between there.
And that process,
a lot of data can get lost
in that process, right?
Some quality assurance person could say,
well,
I thought that it was going to
come yesterday, but it didn't.
And someone delayed a shipment from this
city, this city. And so that kind of, uh,
that kind of error just
trickles throughout the entire
supply chain and can ruin
everything, right? So, uh, there,
there are big problems
with the supply chain.
But what I found very
interesting is, you know, in a,
in a survey that a bunch of professionals,
a sea level professionals were asked,
what is the aspect of digitization?
Hilarious word that you believe will
drive the most value in the future.
Most of them said supply chain visibility,
right?
So usually you don't hear that
much about the supply chain.
When you're thinking about
applications of blockchain, you're,
you're thinking about banking,
you're thinking about, you know,
perhaps real estate or
betting or gambling.
But I believe that the supply chain is,
as of now,
the biggest industry for blockchain,
like this is where the, the,
the most immediate real world use case
comes from, right? And the reason is,
is because there's so many problems
with the supply chain as of now that
blockchain could help fix a,
so let's think about all the ways
that the supply chain is wrong, right?
The supply chain is a sub optimal.
So one would be ocean frights for example.
They account for 90% of goods
traded globally as a huge number.
90% of goods traded globally.
Enter the ocean fright,
enter an ocean freight at some point.
Now the,
the problem with ocean freights
is shipping information
usually traveled through
numerous companies and contractors.
And this can cause a delay and remember
a delight anywhere in the supply chain,
not just costs time. It
costs real money, right?
Because these intermediaries are all
right now trying to predict what day
something will come to them,
the product,
and when they can then
inspect it or whatever,
their job is a and then they can send
it on throughout the rest of the chain.
So there's a lot of problems here when
it comes to planning and forecasting,
asset management, visibility, procurement,
manufacturing, financials, right? There's,
there's a lot to keep track of, right?
For APP, at least for one company.
But the problem is when
it comes to supply chain,
there's not just one company
involved, right? Ideally,
you know, if I wanted a desk,
I would just go directly to the factory
or I would ping the factory and say I
want a desk.
And that desk could just like be drone
shipped over to me and that's it.
But that's unfortunately
not the way the world works.
There's a lot of intermediaries there,
right?
How much are you supposed to pay a driver?
When are they supposed to know when
a certain product has been shipped?
How can all of them trust each
other to have done their job? Right?
How can the driver trust that the
package was delivered at this point?
How can the consumer,
the end consumer,
no trust that the product that they're
using is an actual quality product, right?
Because if all this data is
stored in a database on a website,
any of the intermediaries could
easily modify that data. Right. To,
to fit their best interest.
Right? Because remember,
there's not one company in the supply
chain, there are multiple companies.
So the problem is that they all
have competing interests. So it,
you have to trust all of them.
And this is a problem, right?
Because any of them can just
modify something and say, Oh,
you know what the date for this
product was meant for this day.
And then the other person will say,
no, we had a deal. And they'll say, oh,
well look at the database.
And they changed it. And you
just have to go with that,
right? Because you can't, you, you
just have to trust them as of now. Uh,
and this is a problem. Right? And that's
just, that's just based on trust alone,
right? So trust is a big problem
when it comes to supply chain.
All of these intermediaries
with competing interests,
these businesses have to trust each
other to create this cohesive chain of
operations to get a product from
the factory to the consumer.
So there has to be a better way. And
that's just one problem, right? There's,
there are other problems.
It's difficult for small businesses
to get into the game, right?
Like if you're a small business,
usually manufacturers only want to
deal with big companies. Why? Again,
it comes down to trust.
There.
There has to be some reputation because
these big companies have been ripped off
so many times.
They want to trust a larger company
with a huge history of clientele because
they have to, or else they would
lose money. But as a small business,
you don't have that reputation.
Number two is that there's an
opaque procurement process.
31% of buyers site finding
the right manufacturing
suppliers is a standard issue
in the production process. Okay? That's
another one. Outdated technology, right?
We're talking about decades old system.
Some of these supply chain services
are running on Ms dos. Yes.
Really little to no Ip protection. That's
a, that's a whole nother can of worms,
right? Ip, intellectual
property. Who owns what,
when was something created?
Who's putting a timestamp and a
creation stamp on what these are?
These are stamps that should be immutable
and right now they are totally mutable,
mutable,
or modifiable.
So the solution to this is the blockchain.
Okay?
And I'm surprised that there aren't more
companies that are using the blockchain
to make the supply chain
process more efficient, right?
This is a huge opportunity
to, to make, uh, a business,
right?
This is,
this is an opportunity to create a
sustainable business using blockchain
technology, supply chain.
There it is. Now there's,
because there are so many different sub
applications within the supply chain
industry, right? Digital ownership.
Who owns what proof of origin did this
crop come at that was this crop organic?
What that did? Was it
handled properly? Um,
who handled it wa how many
intermediaries did it go through?
Trusted maintenance tracking.
Did this product go through these specific
intermediaries that we wanted it to?
Did it go through this quality
assurance process we wanted it to,
did they water it? Did they peel it of
any thing that it didn't need? You know,
if it's a vegetable,
there's a lot of things that you know,
that there's a lot of issues regarding
trust that all these intermediaries have
to deal with.
So what blockchain can do is,
if we think about a blockchain,
it is an immutable ledger. Okay.
So it's just think of it as like a
huge column of transactions, right?
Like an excel spreadsheet.
The best part about a blockchain is
that nobody can modify it, right?
Once it's been created,
no one can modify it.
It's read only access as a
read only data structure.
Now this is perfect for the supply chain.
Once one intermediary does their job,
they can, they can send as a
transaction that data to the blockchain.
Then the second part, the second
intermediary intermediary knows that this,
this person timestamped on the, now I
know, you know, whatever this person did,
and then they'll do the same.
And then that just keeps going.
And when it gets to the end consumer,
the end consumer can say, where did,
where,
where is my product from?
And rather than having to
trust the label on the product,
they can literally look at the blockchain
and it will show the history of where
that product has been.
Okay.
But that's just for the consumer,
right? We can think about the retailer.
We can think about the store,
we can think about the third
party logistics companies.
All of these intermediaries can
benefit, uh, from, from the blockchain,
like using the blockchain. In
this case right there, the,
the logistics companies are
notified of the origin of a product.
The retailer gets to, um,
add updates to its data,
rector records automatically because
it's listening to the blockchain.
A store has full transparency on
every single delivery order. Uh,
there's a lot there,
you know,
because consumers can just scan a QR
code on some product and immediately know
where, where it came from,
which is a perfect use case.
Okay.
But the problem is that like not many
companies have done this well by the way.
Like there's so many companies that say
we are supply chain for blockchain and
they don't actually have any,
uh, customers or clients,
but I found s sync fab and sync.
That seems pretty cool if we go to,
let's see,
blockchain documents.
Yeah.
And then in the presentation,
see some of their clients,
which I think is very,
very cool.
Okay.
They've got some governments here,
which is very cool. They're there.
They've been working with some
governments, uh, city of San Leandro,
a city of San Francisco, uh,
and some other ones. But yeah,
these are real clients of this
company has been tracking for years.
They'd been working with these
clients for years. And yeah,
I think that's pretty cool. So if you
want to look at a real world use case,
it's sync fab manufacturing,
supply chain, blockchain.
Very cool stuff. But uh, right. So,
so instead of having multiple
versions of truth, right,
remember these companies are all
silos with their own databases.
What if there was one single force of
truth that they all had to listen to?
Right? This is the source of truth
immutable. It will never change it.
Records cords,
everything that happens across the supply
chain and you can read it and you can
look at it and it's,
it will never change and you can trust it.
Why I've gone into that in other videos,
why the blockchain is immutable,
just a youtube search,
Saroj blockchain
decentralized applications that that will
get you the, the first link. So, so how,
so how has a real world application
like sync fab actually doing this? Like,
what are they doing that makes,
uh,
that that gives them the ability to have
clients and build an actual business
around this? Right? So we think about
the manufacturer and the buyer rights.
So you have a manufacturer and they create
these products and then you have the
buyer.
They're buying these products.
What incentive does each of
these parties have to, to,
to deal with this service? Well,
for the hardware buyer, right?
The person who wants to buy some
hardware for the manufacturer,
it eliminates all the intermediaries
and brokers in that process,
which saves them money and they can
go directly to the manufacturer.
It's kind of like Uber for manufacturing
on demand manufacturing. Now,
if you've ever tried to contact
a manufacturer or a factory,
if you have a hardware
startup for example,
it's a lot of work and it's not easy
and it's a very dated process, right?
Sometimes you have to fill out a form and
then you have to wait like three weeks
and then they'll get back to
you. But with this, you just,
you get a listing of them on demand, I
want this. And then it comes back to you.
Now on the manufacturer side,
how were they incentivized? Well,
it eliminates their marketing costs.
Right now they have to find buyers.
So they have to put real
money into marketing their,
their manufacturing service.
But this, the smart contracts
that sink that provides,
connects them directly to the
buyer and guarantees payment.
So remember how I said how
small businesses usually
can't come into this game
because there's a reputation system while,
because of smart contracts,
they can because they can trust that
even small players will do their part
because there's a trusted,
uh,
blockchain in the middle that is a
smart contract that escrows the funds.
So you can't just back out of it because
there's a two of three escrow signature,
which we'll get into and they've got
their own token. It's called Mfg. Uh,
but I really found their smart
contract architecture. Interesting.
So a person has an identity,
they'll make a purchase order.
Now a purchase order can consist of so
many different features, right from,
from your id to your payment terms,
whatever your inspection report,
and then they'll make
a payment using that.
And it goes from in progress
canceled to complete it. They can,
a buyer can make a purchase order on
a smart using a smart contract on an
immutable blockchain. That's it. So if
you've ever worked with the supply chain,
that's a, that's a new concept. It's,
it's never been that easy for a buyer to
just make a poor purchase order without
having to deal with at least two or
three intermediaries when it comes to
hardware manufacturing. But
with this, they can, right.
So this provides a high quality quotes
from the source on demand purchasing for
the, for the hardware innovators and a
direct connection to the manufacturing
facility, which eliminates marketing
costs for the manufacturers,
which I think they even have an APP,
which is super cool and it's,
it's a pretty app, you know, et Cetera, et
cetera. Uh, but yeah, that's the PR. It's,
it's a,
it's a 13 step process.
If we look at the logic
for the smart contract. Um,
but I think a better way to explain this
process is to really build a very bare
bones version of an asset
tracker. Okay. So let's do,
we'll create a bare bones
asset tracker, um, in Remix,
which is the solidity compiler.
Now,
sink fab has built their token on if
[inaudible] if your room's blockchain and
it's an Erc 20 token,
they also are using the ethereum
blockchain to builders smart contracts.
So what we're going to try
to do is replicate a version,
a version of sync fabs code,
but a very simple version of that code.
And all this is going to do is it's
going to track an assets on a blockchain.
So where do we start?
So the first thing we want to do if we're
going to structure this smart contract
is to say that we're going to do the
pragma mark solidity and then, uh,
say what version it is. So remember, uh,
the pragmas are known from whom cut
from compilers like GCC, you know,
they give the compiler additional
information on how to process the,
the giving code that even tells the
compiler to use the highest version
available using this little mark above,
above that mark.
Okay. So, uh, once we
have that, we can say,
let's assume that we
have are an asset's file.
Now the assets file will contain more
metadata about the assets that we have,
assets that solidity.
Okay.
So in our asset tracker, so this is,
this is what it does. It's a tracker.
Now normally we would have a
database on a web app that does this,
but because this contract will live
on a blockchain, nobody owns this.
So it's an unstoppable asset
tracker, right? Nobody can modify it.
Now this asset, this asset tracker
will contain an ID for the asset,
which we'll call, which is a
string, which we'll call Id.
And we'll create a getter and a setter
for this so we can get and set this, um,
whenever we create it,
right?
So we want to create an ID and then we
want to get it later so we can verify
it.
So this ID is going to return a string.
Yeah.
Or it's got the string,
which is the ID. Okay.
So there's that part and there's a
bunch of different types we could use
whenever we're coding solidity,
there's bools, there's, you
know, there's static. Um,
I've got a list of all the different
solidity types for you in the video
description.
So when,
when it comes to tracking the data
structure that we're going to use,
I'm going to say,
let's create that data structure.
That data structure has called an asset,
right?
So what is contained in an asset?
Well, an asset has a name, right?
And asset has a description.
It has a source,
or we can call it a
manufacturer in this case.
And we've have some bullying that says,
has it been initialized? We're not,
which will tell the rest of the smart
contract whether or not it's been
initialized. So, so this is
just a simple example. Remember,
assets can have so many different features
as we saw before. And acid can have,
you know, virgin control version numbers,
it can have a report, you know, et cetera.
But this is just a very simple example.
But in order to store these assets
were we are going to create these two
mappings.
That's going to allow us to store acid
properties as well as the relation
between assets and wallets
based on the you, you ids,
which are there unique
identification strings.
So it's a private asset store.
So that's the first,
um, mapping we'll create that's going
to be used to store assets under their
respective you,
you id,
and then we'll have
another mapping that maps.
Okay.
The asset store from the name,
the description,
this is, I mean this is for
the wallet store, right? So
true. What else do we
want to say? Manufacturer
and, well, this is to store assets,
seizing their respective you UID.
And then we'll have one another mapping
and then we'll have another
mapping for the address,
uh,
to make an assignment
of an asset to a wallet.
So,
and we can say
message,
just send her your you id.
Okay.
Equals true.
Okay, so that was, okay. So that's
the first part. Now for different,
there could be a number of real
world events that could happen here.
Writes like asset creation,
asset transfer,
and we're going to define counterparts
for that in this smart contract. Right?
So what are some possible things
that could happen to an asset? Well,
one could be the creation of an asset,
right?
So what would be the parameters
for asset creation? Well,
we want the address of the account,
right? We want, it's it's Id,
it's unique identifier. We
want, what else do we want?
We want its manufacturer and we want,
I think that's it. Yeah,
those are the three. Uh,
what else do we want? So
let's just, we want, uh,
to be able to reject a creation.
So we'll say event reject, create.
Okay.
And then we want another one
that's going to be asset transfer,
asset transfer.
And we want one more,
which is going to be reject transfer.
And this is going to be addressed account.
Of course there's going to be from,
because the t because
these last two are from,
mmm.
This is going to be a message.
This is,
we don't need one for a transfer.
And then we have a message for
reject rejection message and,
hmm.
Okay, cool. So there's that.
Now we can create an asset.
So let me just write out,
um,
okay.
Okay. So now let me write out just a
simple function for asset creation. Try.
So if we want to create an
asset, we can say, okay,
so using what we've just created before,
let's say to create an asset,
we need snake, we needed a
description for this, for the asset,
and we need the manufacturer manufacturer.
Now once we have that,
we can
right this out.
So if the asset stores a unique identifier
is initialized,
yeah,
then we're going to reject
the creation step.
Okay.
Same to sender and the U U I d
are going to be as as parameters.
Um,
and what that means is if it's already
initialized asset with this you UID
already created,
it means it's already been created.
Now, once we have that, that's
just kind of our failure case.
Then once we have that,
then we can say,
let's store if it, if it, if
it hasn't been created before,
then let's create the asset,
the name description,
true.
And the Wallet Store, right? Cause
we're going to store the asset, uh,
we have,
we're going to store it in our wallet and
we're going to create,
that's
factor there.
Okay. So what, okay, so what this
is saying is that in order to,
let me just make sure this is all good.
Yup.
So what is the saying is that in
order to transfer an asset, uh, we're,
we're going to create a
function that takes the address,
the target wallet along with the Asset Id.
Okay.
And we check those two preconditions.
And the asset is if the
asset actually exists, uh,
then we don't want to recreate it.
But if it doesn't,
then we're going to create the
asset ourselves. Now this is,
this is the type of function that we
would call from web three dot. Js. Right?
So this is the,
okay,
this is the contract that we would deploy
to the blockchain and then we would
use wet three dot js.
So then called this contract
specifically create asset using the Nate,
the description, the manufacturer. Okay.
Sing Fab has their own smart contracts
that we could look at on get hub. Um,
they have quite a lot
of smart contracts here,
but if you're looking for a good source
to learn about a production ready,
smart contract code for supply chains,
definitely check them out. Uh, yeah.
So that's it for this video.
I hope you found it useful and yeah.